hi I'm Erik Bosse and the ventures
endgame is nearly upon us and over the
past year since infinity war broke our
hearts the most intriguing mystery that
I personally have loved losing my mind
over is a question of dr. strange in the
assumption that he must have
deliberately surrendered the time stone
to Thanos because the Avengers losing
what's necessary for the one at a 14
million 605 ultimate futures in which
they eventually found a way to win I
have explained some possibilities for
dr. Strange's secret plan before but
with some interesting new clues from the
recent and game trailer my weekly
rewatched of all the MCU films and a
minor overdose of cough syrup some of
this is starting to align in a way that
kind of makes sense to me and I want to
share this mental vomit with you because
I love you more in case i accidentally
say something that ends up being right
and it ruins your life okay when Yuri
watch the moment Doctor Strange
surrenders the time stone notice that it
is glowing I brought this up before but
throughout the movie the Infinity stones
give off a normal red steam glow but
then they only shine brighter like this
when they're being used so many of us
have speculated that strange could
actually be using the time stone in this
moment a few months back related theory
blew up on reddit from user Raul V sorry
if I'm saying that wrong that dr.
strange might have put the Avengers in a
time loop the way he put himself in a
time loop to wear down Dormammu so just
like how strange confronted Dormammu an
undefined number of times dying and
undefined infinite number of horrible
deaths
his suggestion to Tony Stark about 14
million futures that he saw could refer
to each time the loop with the Avengers
ends with their failure and resets
giving them a new crack at it
so maybe the time stone glowing could
mean this is a moment Doctor Strange
began his spell with it establishing the
in in the out points for the loop the
redditors singled out an unusual line
back in age of Ultron from Bruce Banner
right after stark suggested installing
Jarvis into the Android body eventually
leading division I'm gonna loop I'm
caught in a time loop this is exactly
where it all went wrong mmm now what
every watch's seemed closely actually
got an even subtler detail that could be
a game-changer all loop around to it a
bit but could the Avengers be in a time
loop that extends that far back in the
MCU timeline well the end game trailers
had been planes
weird games with callbacks to pass the
MCU moments some of the footage is a bit
more obvious shown for emotional context
while other old footage might have been
tweaked with VFX to look new which the
Russos have admitted to doing but in the
most recent trailer there was this odd
bit of audio that a cop from Tony Stark
was he's injured what's weird is the
Russo brothers lifted this exact same
audio from Stark in a major scene in age
of Ultron worthy of injures we can bust
arms dealers on the live long David bad
up there that's that's the a game maybe
it's just a coincidence that they pulled
this relatively random phrase from the
exact line that were shadowed the title
in the story line up of the Avengers end
game film or maybe the movie itself will
revisit moments from age of Ultron via a
time loop that the Avengers are already
in and one key decision that they could
have made differently in those days
leaving the mind stone alone leave it
alone the mind stone was the first
Infinity stone Thanos was in possession
of he let Loki borrow it for a scepter
to try to obtain the space stone and the
mine stone was the final stone Thanos
acquired the bulk of the infinity war
plot was centered around protecting and
defending that stone in particular and
throughout the years with vision it's
the one stone that the Avengers had the
most control over so look again at that
banner line I'm gonna loop I'm caught in
a time this is exactly where it all went
wrong
notice how the editing weirdly jumps on
banner shifting him from the left side
of the frame to the right without even
cutting back to Stark for a reaction
it's kind of like an awkward hiccup
almost like a record skipping you don't
normally see this in film editing unless
it's motivated by some deeper reason
could that deeper reason be that this is
evidence of a loop repeating a second
black cat glitch in the matrix and by
banner saying this is exactly where it
all went wrong maybe he's hinting that
experimenting with a mine stone and
berthing vision set them on a path where
they'd be even more vulnerable to Thanos
there is other evidence from the endgame
trailers that the Marvel characters
could be reliving their histories in a
loop but first thank you to our sponsor
Skillshare for helping us make this
video Skillshare is an online learning
community with more than 25,000 classes
in design business technology and more
it's premium membership gives you
unlimited
access so that you can join the classes
and communities that are just right for
you when your goals whether you want to
feel your curiosity your creativity or
even your career skills share is the
perfect place to keep you learning and
thriving I love breaking down subtle
filmmaking details and knowing what
normal film editing looks like helps me
identify when it's being subverted to
try to convey some deeper meaning I'm
actually taking the Skillshare class
power video editing Premiere Pro in 45
minutes with Don don'll ooh it's a great
crash course for someone like me to pick
up some tricks on how footage is
assembled and edited into a narrative
Skillshare is also super affordable an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month to join more than 7
million creators learning with skill
share and is a special offer just for
you guys
the first 500 of our subscribers to use
the link in the description below will
get a 2 month free trial so it's
definitely worth trying out just go to
sk l sh slash new rockstars 11 or click
on the link in the description okay back
to the other time loop evidence in the
in-game trailer we spotted the Benatar
departing what looks like the planet
Morag the abandoned planet that Peter
quill visited at the beginning of the
first guardians of the galaxy to obtain
the orb containing the Power Stone but
one thing I didn't talk about in my
breakdown was this other planet behind
panels his ship the sanctuary to that
planet surface kind of looks like it's
in flames and some are speculating that
this could be Zander home of the Nova
Corps in guardians where the Power Stone
ended up being stored Thanos presumably
destroyed Zander to steal the Power
Stone before the events of Infinity Ward
perhaps the smokey debris covered
battlefield that the Avengers are
confronting Danis on and these endgame
trailers is actually the ruins of Zander
that would explain why Danis is still
wearing his helmet remember he took off
this helmet after getting the space
stones some time later and this could be
why he still has to beam down to this
planet's surface because he doesn't yet
have the space stone this blue light
beaming is how we see the black order
beam down from there Q ships so the
Avengers could be earlier in the loop
meeting Thanos on the ruins of Zander
trying to block him from getting his
first infinity stone for his gauntlet
and just hoping the mad Titan can be
taken down without his fancy glove look
I know many of you may be saying I'm
reaching by the way welcome to new
rockstars we do a lot of that here but
we do know that Doctor Strange will have
some role to play an endgame and that it
will involve the quantum realm and we
can thank Tom Holland for that scoop he
lines though he has to talk about so
much quantum realm stuff just idea back
in the Doctor Strange film strange
actually briefly visits the quantum
realm a place and which according to
hank pym time and space become
irrelevant and when strange passed
through it the Ancient Ones voiceover
implied that the quantum realm was
benevolent and life-giving now the
director of the Doctor Strange movie
scott derrickson actually just tweeted
something interesting which now that I
think of it technically makes this video
a nuisance said that while editing
Doctor Strange he ran into Joe Russo who
pitched him the basic story for both
infinity war and end game and derrickson
told him that if he could make the first
movie work the second would be effing
incredible now you can draw your own
conclusions from what this means but to
me this implies some coordination
between the stories of dr. strange
perhaps best known for introducing the
multiverse in time loops into the MCU
and endgame a movie that could be doing
a lot with the multiverse in time loops
add this to the other clues that we know
about dr. strange and time loops
throughout the MCU and I think it's a
very real possibility for endgame and if
it isn't it should be right because time
loops are fun Groundhog Day
edge of tomorrow Bush and Dolph I
actually assume that every movie I see
is part of a grand time loop in which
we're just seeing one of those loops
just let me have my fun comment down
below if you think the Avengers could be
within a time loop and follow me on
Instagram and Twitter a ta vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for deep
dives into everything in game related
even if you think time loops are too
much of a stretch
oh oh hi I'm Erik Bosse an Avengers
endgame is nearly up